[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I just want to make
sure my soundboard is recording and the
cameras are rolling yeah I know I've
talked about it I do all of it now since
Ryan's not here I mean I don't do the
major the major made here editing he
does all that but uh how's everybody
feeling you know some weeks I feel like
I'm like I got this man I got this I
could handle this and then other weeks
I'm like all talk to myself a little
more but the more I'm creative and the
more I do things and talk to people and
take walks and play with my dogs
I just feel happier stay away from the
caffeine late in the afternoon and
that's gonna kill me in the outro we'll
talk about my patrons I am on the patron
patreon I think I have the best patreon
in the world inside of you podcast
patreon it's such an amazing community
and put it this way there's a bunch of
tiers and I don't I I started to do
something that's not even on there which
is these live YouTube's for just my
patrons and we just jam you know they
send just play this song and I'll just
try to play different songs and we'll
talk and it's fun I really I'd say oh
you're doing it for them no they don't
do doing it for me and another thing on
the side is completely different project
completely different because obviously
inside of you podcast this is a podcast
and these guys are supporters of the
podcast and it's sort of this whole
community but Jon Heder and I have
always wanted to do a project with
horror movies because we always watch
them every week so Jon Heder Napoleon
Dynamite blades of glory he and I have
an exclusive patreon and it's called
where have all the good horror movies
gone and it's pretty neat and we just
started that so I hope you'll uh you
know you can look at that and also my
favorite charities Ronald McDonald House
of Los Angeles Tom Welling Kristin Kreuk
and I did the omaze comm slash reunion
you could raises money and you could win
a virtual interview with me and Tom and
Kristen and it's fantastic amazed calm
slash reunion what else food on foot org
one of my favorites
they've been raising a lot of money and
let me tell you something thank you
because my friend Danson Rob called me
and said dude a lot of your people
listen to your podcast I've been
donating all my holy Sh it's just it's
too much it's honestly I have the best
fans in the world I don't care what
anybody else says I mean it these are
loyal son of a guns right here and I'm
gonna name them some of them at the end
but all my patrons are badass great
guests he's back but now you get to see
him a lot to talk about I always love
talking to this guy
you become buds just a great guy a
positive guy a stand-up guy someone who
will tell you how it is and we get into
it and it was just as easy the second
time sometimes you think there's nothing
to talk about well there's way more to
talk about talk about a guy going on
tour and jump-starting that career he's
he's a force to be reckoned with you'll
learn a lot just from like the
confidence and the way he thinks I think
that helps it helped me sort of
understand myself better or understand
all of us a little better you know and I
like that he likes the podcast I got to
tell you I wish I could play a he left
me a memo we didn't even really know
each other that well but he left me a
member what he thought about the podcast
and it meant a lot to me it really it
really did all right guys let's let's
get in Dane Cook it's my
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you can hear me good now though can't
you I can hear you so [ __ ] good man
goddammit you sound good thanks man
it's been it's been a crazy day I know
this is not about me this is about you
this is an interview with one class well
I had Botox day a lot of Botox not on my
face on my neck so this doctor thought
cuz all my surgeries and I have a lot of
tightness and stuff he goes let's try
some Botox so we did a hundred units to
try and give me some relief and so I got
a whole bunch of injections and now he
says it will take a few days so have you
ever gotten any kind of Botox and
muscles or any tightness the only place
I've ever done Botox cuz I have a friend
who's a dermatologist is in my armpits
mmm I heard that stop sweat a lot of my
friends did that yeah I mean it was like
I was touring so much and I found that
I'm only a person that except for a
little bit of a a glisten I was getting
I was getting the sweat pits and my
buddy was like I could I could injection
but I think he's kidding he's like six
little injections and you won't sweat
for like six months and I'm like oh
great
until you realize well the sweats gotta
come out somewhere else so it's like
suddenly your [ __ ] thighs are just
seeking is that true well I didn't sweat
out of my pits for like six months I was
amazing but I did I did notice other
parts of my body seemed very moist would
you exchange armpit sweat for a thigh
sweat I'll take the five sweat any day
over the armpit sweat it being you know
what it is and this is gonna sound
really [ __ ] weird but I'm a weird
dude about little things the aesthetic
of to uneven pit stains is what bothers
me more than the sweating or anything
else Richard Pryor when he did live on
Sunset Strip that silk shirt goes
through so many different it looks like
an atlas that's been updated year after
year with like landmass it's in it
[ __ ] drove me crazy as a kid and I
was like I don't like things not being
little things not being aesthetic like
sweat pit if I could sweat it the exact
same circumference at the same time to
reach pit I'd be okay with
what's that word symmetrical symmetrical
is a word that could be used to to
scroll most like this wet it's
symmetrical you got even amounts of
sweat on the left pit right Pitt Brad
Pitt you're doing well there I have a
question looking I see me but all I see
is like this much of your hat oh [ __ ]
yeah hold on I love that you've got the
jerk poster there see your favorite of
all time I sent this to him
and I was like look at this picture that
I got of you and he wrote back he's like
oh yeah I remember that are you serious
oh yeah all right just so much work you
said you said something you're like oh
my god Steve Martin you got this picture
Steve Martin you're looking at my jerk
poster and then you said yeah I text him
or you email it you have Steve Martin's
information book which is if you haven't
read it is well it's flipped but born
standing up and when that came out I had
the opportunity to have a lunch with him
to talk all things comedy but I had met
him previously very briefly I was at the
comic strip in New York this is like
2004 and Lorne Michaels had come to
watch me dealer said and I get into the
club and I don't see Lauren I don't see
anybody it's just a packed crowd I go on
stage and when I came off the stage
my buddy Matt Frost who was my Booker
then and still I work with now he's like
do you know who's here
and I'm like yeah Lauren Michaels came
down he told me he was coming he goes he
brought Steve [ __ ] Martin so I got to
meet Steve I got you know great pictures
have a chat with him briefly about
comedy and then he went on his way in
some years later when he wrote the book
I got a copy I just got a copy of it
sent from my publicist and said can I
meet him and the next day I had lunch
with him and this was was this at the
height of your career well by height of
my career you mean today well yes
because well we'll talk about that
because there's a lot of great [ __ ]
going on until all this should have
but no I know you're joking I know it's
a joke it's all joke yes it was it was a
white-hot moment and of course Steve had
written something really cool on the
book with which was like pertaining to
the fact that you know that this book
was something that I think he would
probably have it I think he wrote
something like we have another one
heroes dear Dane read this and just
substitute your name for mine Steve
Martin Wow
and so turn lunch the next day with the
guy that ultimately you know pre-dice
having his explosive moment I was
finally sitting with the Yoda for me to
be able to talk shop well I'm hoping
that this was no this wasn't this wasn't
post Botox shots for sweat from your
friend this is pre some guessing you
were probably sweating you told me this
in the last interview
oh I don't normally get nervous but I do
get trepidatious and I was definitely
feeling that before I went in also
knowing that he's he's he's a bit more
of like introvert introvert yeah so
leading into it knowing I go into
introvert mode and if he's there then
like what the [ __ ] is this gonna be it's
gonna be just like very zen um but it
was great it turned out to be a really
eye-opening lunch how long an hour like
an hour and a half and it was
comfortable you feel comfortable after a
while you're like I like this guy I
think this guy likes me were you
concerned about him liking you because
that's what I would be doing I'd be
sitting in a room going I just want this
person to like me I was I mean I was
obviously hoping that based on that the
things that he was that he perceived
from my stand-up and then just some of
them the nice elements of the
conversation that yes in my head I was
like I wonder if I'm gonna have like a
friendship with with Steve Bart will I
be will I be incommunicado with him on a
regular basis after this but more than
anything just knowing how the industry
is and how we all cross paths even
friendships sometimes you don't see each
other for years yeah I was just going to
take full advantage of
the hour or whatever I was on the clock
Steve Martin this is it because that
could be your only time yet think about
that's how I think I you know I've
talked about this but when you're on set
with somebody you admire and it's the
end of the shoot or whatever or you you
meet somebody random to me I'm like this
is probably it well I'm not gonna meet
this person again why don't I just say
something that I mean why don't I just
like get a picture get it a lot of
people aren't that way a lot most people
most actors I've talked to like no I
don't need a picture with somebody no I
don't need this
III want one if I like the person I
admire someone I want because I always
think my career is over it now today
it's gonna be over today and I want to
say hey you know a new Steve Martin it's
like it's also that thing of someday I
wanna be able to show my kids you know
we all everybody's going in different
directions you may never see work with
these people again so you want to be
able to say hey look I know that I'm
probably a you know a nerd or lame to
you but I've worked with some iconic
people so yeah why not go for the go for
the picture I say do you notice are you
very hyper aware when you're walking in
with some of the that caliber and by the
way you're you're like in your element
you're like oh they people know who you
are this time it's like it's not like
Steve Martin is walking in with Michael
Rosenbaum it's Steve Martin's walking
him Dane Cook right the people that were
already in the restaurant like some of
the reactions were straight out of like
a badly scripted movie where one guy was
like he cooks with Steve Martin like I
heard him say that he cooks with Steve
Martin right there it was like I was
like I'm I can't [ __ ] believe it
either and he just like that guy laughed
it would have been better of you and
Steve Martin's with Dane Cook he was
very subdued when I first sat down like
he was he was he was so like laid-back
or you know chilled to the point where I
had to go into what I call like
meet-and-greet mode which is you know
when I'm meeting fans and I'm feeling
kind of shy I have to become like a
somewhat of a talk show host right so
immediately I found myself probably
coming in a little hot by being like
very very nice to see you mr. Steve
Martin I can say I'm familiar with your
work like something just to get it my
seat in my
my sneakers have formed two fists you
know like that's where I hold a lot of
my attention normally see it if I'm
nervous with you now then like my feet
have rolled up under and it's just kind
of a huff as I'm hoping that he doesn't
go I'm [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] this
[ __ ] you I just walked but he you know I
did a movie with him and people like oh
here we go get Nam I just remember I was
like holy [ __ ] Steve Martin Steve Martin
and all my scenes were with him small
scenes but I had this terrible wig and I
had to whatever and I remember the first
end set I was just standing I didn't
know anybody you know like I'm a social
guy and I wanna I want people to like me
and stuff and I remember Steve Martin
who just comes home goes so tell me
about this Smallville oh my god I go hey
yeah it's and we talked and I'd sit at
the table at lunch you know and he'd
come up and go is anyone sitting here
he would sit with me as I look like the
nerdy alone kid which I always was and
then I became something I guess
eventually and you know people I guess
sort of pretended to like me but I have
friends that like me but you know so he
was he has that awesome energy and I
loved watching him work the guy he's one
of those guys who he did it taking he's
run over the camera guy oh oh I could be
bigger there I could be bigger there I
could do that you know I learned a lot
from that yeah what a privilege to have
worked with him like you did what I got
from him was like wow this guy is the
ultimate pro because he's really all
about the I hate the word character but
the character that he becomes in
performance the elevated version of
himself but in real life he's actually
just more cerebral completive and you
don't I mean yeah I went running numbers
just so laid-back and so in kind of
inside himself that it makes you
appreciate all his performances even
more yes
I wondered up that about you know I'm
not comparing but I'm saying thank you
know well I'd like to compare myself
with Steve Martin right now no but I
think that it's sort of I think people
are the it's the other way around like
they see I mean obviously someone's but
when I was Lex Luthor they would people
thought I was a serious billionaire
brilliant mastermind and they meet me in
there like oh my god like women would be
turned
more when they met me they were like you
know oh you're not that smart you know
no but I think that I was sort of like
you know with Steve Martin you see this
fun-loving guy man usually always this
introvert and I was sort of like all
over the place where people are like and
they couldn't believe that I had a
personality and I was flying and I did
you know what I mean it was the opposite
do you think that works better you know
cuz Steve not Steve Jim Carrey Jim
Carrey is like one of those introverts
it's sometimes I think is he really an
introvert do you think some people just
play that game play that card well yeah
I'm sure that some people do I mean
everybody kind of like wants to put up
you know what's their excuse to put up
the castle door so that they can kind of
be like you know you know not have to
feel like they're on I do know people
like that I know people who're the
opposite there on all the time and they
are always finding a way to spark some
kind of moment with people for me I'm
glad I'm kind of bummed like more middle
of the road you know I'm I'm comfortable
chatting with people and so that being
said I mean just being able to sit with
this guy who was so [ __ ] laser
focused to perform in front of 20,000
people and yet you can see that just one
on one even that is probably too big of
a crowd for him to some extent I wonder
if there's a way to learn that is there
a way to you've always been this
confident guy you go onstage this is
your home is there a way to learn that
at a or is it when you get to a certain
age this is just you you can't change
your sort of uh yeah I think it's like
all that stuff the confidence and
everything that people see is from see
from you know from me as a performer
that was like [ __ ] brick by brick
building myself up to actually believing
that I had the ability to connect and
perform for people like I don't I make
no bones about it that was like harder
than performing was walking to the stage
to perform the performing was like oh I
can play this is like you could be
childlike you can you can be all the
thing you give your Heidi guided
performance you can be sad you can be
vulnerable you can be [ __ ] angry you
can get mad at heckler and you can say
[ __ ] that if you set it on the street
you be [ __ ] sued or you be you know
ostracized from the office
I love the protective bubble of
the stage but getting from the back of
the room to the stage took a lot of
years to make that walk and feel worthy
of the guy that would finally be up
there so you felt there was a time and
until you did the put the hours and it's
like becoming in a doctor you know
you're going to med school you're going
you're going to the grind until you know
your [ __ ] until you've learned until
you're sweating and you're exhausted and
you're and eventually hopefully a good
doctor comes out of it all somebody
who's confident somebody knows who's
what what they're talking about is that
sort of a good analogy no okay I didn't
think it was well the experience your
experience like you didn't just become
confident one day I guess you did but it
took a lot of work yeah all those all
those hours you know the thing is it's
like you know you know so many comedians
you know so many performers like every
it's all in the [ __ ] minutia
everybody brings such a different path
to how they became who they are both in
front of the camera and who they are
when they're you know just know nobody's
around and how do they treat people and
how do they treat themselves the fact of
the matter is to be able to be one of
the people that can exude confidence but
realize wow I came from the quietest you
know gave myself the roughest time in
school and I could barely even walk to
school because the thought of like just
be get walking through the playground of
kids was like devastating and scary for
me for my journey I'm glad that I can
use my platform to exude that confidence
as a person who's like you can get to
where you want to be but it's gonna be a
long slog you gotta [ __ ] put in the
the woman hours the man hours the people
hours to earn whatever it is that you're
chasing after it's not about getting the
thing it really is that I've been
writing a book for the last year and I'm
just finishing up in the last lexicon
Center I'm still coming up with a couple
of titles that's a good title right
there I'm still coming up with titles
title this book touch all this but but
the thing that I learned is like almost
everything right look back I'm like oh
wow I I did not enjoy the completion of
this because once it becomes somebody
else's it's like it's
the my favorite part of any thing
completed is remembering the first call
when I called you up and said dude I got
an idea for something I'm [ __ ]
thinking about doing this thing right
that is my favorite moment me too
it's like you have this moment even from
me when I like I think I write a script
you know and I go this is good this is
good I love this then it gets another
like you said other people's hands and
they start giving you notes like ah you
know I don't think the studios are gonna
I think you should change this and then
you got to get a pitch and then you go
all he says you know god I just like the
idea of doing it it was just me and it
was fun it was cathartic and then it was
then it gets kind of people [ __ ] with it
I mean look it's that thing where once
other people's energy gets involved once
other people's forget about their
confident notes of how they want it some
people are coming at it with their own
insecurities and then projecting it onto
your you know process so you've got to
almost kind of not be bamboozled by the
people telling you this is the right way
or this can't be done because at the at
the end of it is any stand-up comedy
show that I do the the stuff that
connects with people are the things that
were in my brain that I thought was
interesting I shared with you the laugh
is immediate the applause is their end
of story
nobody else impeding on that and I tried
to do everything that way every project
every friendship every the way I deal
with my family I try to have direct
connection give you the truth about how
I feel from the beginning without
impeding on what it is that you're
trying to create have you ever been like
I look I love you whatever I'm here I'm
your friend or you I'm your you're my
age I just don't want you to give me
your opinion on anything is there anyone
that you just don't want to know their
opinion because you seem like the kind
of guy like I'm gonna do my things and
if they laugh I will work it out to the
way I want it and I don't want anybody
other anybody else's opinion but that
being said do you also is there someone
there a few people that you go is this
funny and you actually listen to them
first of all I love that you're moving
around like [ __ ] Paula Poundstone and
one of her early it's uncomfortable told
you I got Botox on my neck this morning
all right go ahead that's a big chair I
like your chair it's big
thing I ever bought with any money
living in my shitty apartment over on
hussy and a Boulevard
I had nothing and I fought this chair
really it's the oldest thing that I've
had no way 97 and it's comfortable I've
lost everything in this chair
I've gained everything in this chair
I've come with up with some of my
greatest ideas in this chair I've come
up with some of my worst ideas I've
slept in it I've done everything that
section the chair Oh sex on the chair of
course look at this thing oh [ __ ] that's
a flexible chair 97 I had $3,500 to my
name basically and I went over to the
valley and I found a place that sold
like full-on like teak desks and
everything in there looked presidential
and I walked through the whole store and
I saw this chair and there was empty
store and I went to the guy who owned it
and I said I want to buy this chair and
he was like why do you want to buy the
chair and I said because I'm trying to
learn to be a writer and I want to sit
someplace comfortable like it you get
another chair on the bench the guys like
he's like this and I'm like well I said
I go I'm gonna you know I I'm a comedian
and I spend a lot of my you know days
like all day I just want to be
comfortable and I want to and he goes uh
you have to buy at all in the meaning I
had to buy the desk and side desk and
the whole thing was like fifty five
hundred dollars and I was like I can't I
can't I wouldn't dislodge her then my
whole apartment I just want the chair
he's like I'm not going to show just a
chair and I walked out to the parking
lot and all of a sudden he goes hey guy
and I turned around and he goes what is
your name and I go my name is Dane Cook
and he goes are you anybody I should
know and I'm like no not not at this
point and he goes uh I will show you the
chair I'll show you the chair you buy
the chair you come back to me when you
become somebody and give me the picture
of your [ __ ] face I put it in my
office
and he sold me the chair for $1,500 and
put it in fat [ __ ] did I have great
pictures of my shitty old apartment of
me sitting in this big chair on my IBM
ThinkPad the first brick [ __ ]
portable computer on final draft one
learning how to write scripts from this
[ __ ] chair did you ever the chair
does the chair of sitting in when I
learned that my brother [ __ ] was
going to jail this is the chair sitting
in when I got my HBO special and Marty
kölner was gonna direct it I mean this
is it this is it you're never giving
that chair up no no matter it's it's
beat-up it's worn out
it looks like the emperor's [ __ ]
throne but it's so comfortable and it's
kind of my good luck chair did you go
back to the guy I did like seven years
later but the place was defunct it was
no longer there that sucks yeah I wish
he would have been there I could see his
face they remembered me know about that
chair remember but you wouldn't sell it
at first cuz you wanted the table to go
with it no but I bought it and then I
walked out and you said are you someone
I should know and I said no but when you
said wait are you famous now guy okay
guy I love when people call each other
guy inside of you is brought to you by
better help online counseling these are
guys you need to talk to I'll tell you
that right now if you're struggling with
stress you know I have stress how could
you not have stress in our lives
especially the way things are right now
you know it's funny how people when when
there's something catastrophic that
happens or something that's just
life-changing or you have death in the
family or whatever that's when people
always if they're gonna get help they go
to help they get help but it's it's
really the before how to handle when
those things come up how to handle
yourself and how to deal with emotions
and things and that's why I think
therapy's so important you do that early
on it's gonna help you in the long run
you know it's like conditions almost
like conditioning in a way to me people
exercise they get in shape I think
mentally we don't exercise and better
help online counseling can help you do
that if you're struggling with stress
anxiety isolation or depression right
now you're definitely not alone if
you're feeling isolated or worried about
the state of things you're not alone
better help offers online licensed
professional counselors who can help you
and better help counselors specialize in
issues as such as depression like I
talked about relationships sleeping
trauma family conflicts LGBT matters
grief self-esteem the list there's a
shopping list of a grocery list of all
the things that people have we all have
connect with your counselor in a safe
and private online environment I think
that's incredibly important anything you
share is confidential and it's easy it's
so easy better help is easy guys you
just simply fill out a questionnaire to
help assess your needs you get matched
with a counselor in less than 24 hours I
think that's always a warrior like I
don't know how to find that as someone
do I have to meet them I don't it's
expensive it says this is all right here
for you easily schedule secure video or
phone sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages Wow
if for any reason you're unhappy with
your counselor you can request a new one
at any time no charge and you can get
professional help when you want it
wherever you are better help is a truly
affordable option in our listeners get
10% off your first month with a discount
code inside so why not get started today
good
help.com / inside that's better
Aichi LP dot-com / inside talk to a
therapist online and get help inside of
you is brought to you by Sun basket oh I
just made the most delicious meal you
know III just I love talking about
products that just are easy to talk
about you know if you're looking to
reduce any unnecessary trips to the
grocery store perhaps and boy those
grocery stores are pretty crazy right
now you need to check out Sun basket
it's perfect delicious it's a solution
for the times we're living in I got the
the roasted salmon with miso glazed
eggplant
telling you you could do this in
literally 15 minutes all these fresh
ingredients are right there for you and
it's fun we have time now we're all at
home so what do we need we need
distractions well how about a healthy
distraction where you can cook a meal
that's all there for you in 15 minutes
it's got everything there for you even I
can do it trust me I'm gonna videotape
myself and you go oh no this guy could
do it you could order from any recipes
across the menu they got paleo
gluten-free Mediterranean vegetarian
they make it easy and convenient
everything pre-portion and ready to prep
and cook you enjoy your dinner full of
organic produce and clean ingredients in
as little as 15 minutes like I said and
son basket facilities have the highest
level of food and employee safety
reinforcing strict adherence to their
existing standard operating procedures
because of the times like these and I
like that I like knowing that people are
thinking about my food and safety just
sayin it right now son basket is
offering $35 off your order that's a lot
of money they're offering $35 off your
order when you go right now to son
basket comm slash IOU and enter promo
code IOU at checkout that son basket
dot-com slash IOU and enter the promo
code I owe you a check out for $35 off
your order
son basket comm slash IOU and enter the
promo code I owe you what do you think
is is obviously you're older now than
you were but like what what's different
what has has evolved in the last how
many years since in the last let's say
ten years I I didn't know you then right
but you just feel like that there's
definitely you sent me a message that
was just incredibly kind in random in at
random in a good way there was this
voicemail and it was just kind of a
personal thing but you were like you
just said something really nice about me
interviewing people and they just have
this clue fluidity about you and blah
blah and I just remember going how
freaking cool is it cuz not many people
have you know know why because you know
being mindful and allowing feelings
about whatever art relationships
anything when something pings you I feel
like it's the responsibility of a
healthy well-rounded person
to give away our power so to speak to
the people around us and I think after
going through the whole multitude of
everything that I experienced good and
bad the thing that changed the most in
the last ten years was like I don't I
don't wanna ever [ __ ] hold a feeling
in if I have an issue I need to vent it
if I feel loved I want to say it if I'm
proud of somebody I want to tell him and
and not to sound like like a little woe
is me about it but I just wish more
people did that for me III do what I
rarely God even in that moment of a
breakthrough moment and I can understand
you know yeah some people probably
thought that I was untouchable or I was
not accessible and there's a lot of
reasoning and I accept all of it but
it's still hurt to feel like wow is
nobody looking and saying dude we know
the sacrifice you put in we're doing it
too [ __ ] good on you man yeah so I do
it for other people I do it and I and
even though I will get it few and far
between when I do receive that back I
know that is a good person a mindful
person yeah you know I think that's true
and I think that especially in in this
business in Hollywood it's like who
really does that and usually it's
artificial right your agents people say
you're the best you're gonna be I you're
gonna be the next wolf they're on like
stop them I'm gonna be the next Will
Ferrell you know but certain people it's
not like you need it but you kinda need
it but it'd be nice if someone like your
peers who you respect just came up to
you go hey man I want just something
it's but it has obviously has to feel
real has to be genuine and that's the
kind of thing that you like when you did
with me was over ran I hadn't talked to
you in a couple weeks whatever I'm just
one of these random things or just a
thought that occurred to you you
translated it hit you you sent it to me
and that I thought that was cool and I
think you're right more people should do
that it's like it's it's not even just
this town it has nothing to do with just
the business it's just human behavior
you know fears people you know you know
putting projecting out there and how
people feel about himself is usually how
they translate and communicate with
other people and I can look at the
people in my life now the people that
I've been communicating with during this
you know fear
a scary time or like the people that
like myself are very settled in to the
things that they've done that are both
successful and should be celebrated and
they also know their you know miss steps
and own it and could talk about failure
in a way that's still funny and poignant
and informative
so I just owned it all dude there's
nothing that we could talk about that
I'm concerned to delve into and say yeah
that was me then versus how I feel about
things going forward now yeah because I
mean you're pretty serious with this
girl you don't really talk about the
girl or you don't mind are you going on
three years in my in my relationship and
they seem really happy
best best the best do you ask her shit's
funny I don't need to know she'll tell
me without you asking yeah no I mean you
know how it is if you with somebody that
that digs your perspective they're gonna
be able to like not only talk it out
when you're when you're onto something
and she knows you know the comedy brain
up she'll company with you like that's
that's a bit that's now she speaks
comedy that's a bit that's a bit and
then sometimes she look at me and be
like yeah that that's only for us babe
that's that's definitely not for public
consumption should he say that you'll
lose your career I should go to your
shows oh yeah she I took her on tour
most of the year last year cuz she's a
musician and she also does Pilates stuff
she's like a private Pilates instructor
so it's great she can kind of hang out
and go places with me and we're sharing
each other's creative journey which is
awesome does she give you Pilates
classes lessons doing when you're on on
the road yeah we've done some like hotel
workouts you know we do the Pilate stuff
in yoga together we actually do yoga
together we go do what we were up until
this new yoga once a week and ya know we
just you know the best relationship
should be boring to anybody else
listening to it because it's just it's
there's no frills no drama it's just a
lot of love man and that's where I want
to be I like that I like that and you
know it's I mean is this affected you I
read some of you
you know you're like your Instagram I
can't wait to look back on this moment
our history and say we made it through
together apart thankful for the ability
to make others laugh to help others
succeed to set an example and to exceed
my own expectations yeah what do you
think you're doing now like when you're
because I don't stay locked in but like
what are you doing during the day is
easy for you cuz someone who's creative
who likes to write who likes to do you
know you just stand up he does it is it
just something like you're okay where
I'm not okay is I you know as a person
who's come up and learn you know having
like fear of abandonment issues and
having to have gone through deep therapy
to be okay being alone I'm glad I went
through all those stages to prepare for
something like this because it's not
easy it doesn't matter you know what you
did ten years ago five years ago like
it's it's all you know it's all how you
feel about the position that you're in
right now and fortunately for me as a
person that can can suffer from anxiety
similar to when I got this chair and I
felt very lonely when I first came to LA
and didn't know anybody and didn't have
any connections or really any anything
to put myself into I fell in love with
writing and this year having written the
book and then we finally get closed in
here I felt comfortable being on my own
you know my girls here but she's also
taking care of her mom
close by so it's you know a lot of time
where I'm here you know working working
on myself but through the book that's
provided me the opportunity to to feel
okay with this not normal situation when
do you feel most anxious uh usually in
the morning it kind of hits me I'm one
of those people I wake up with it before
right before you even wake up arms numb
yeah my mom I just get right it's if you
feel the heaviness and if I don't know
about you but if I don't like get up
pretty quick and get moving that's not
going to be I'm gonna be having
conversations in my head about you know
does this person care about me should I
ask it's like I get over
so that's where it lands on me in the
morning well that that's exactly you
know when I went to the therapist in
Connecticut years ago this one therapist
I remember she goes so how are the
mornings ago I wake up with anxiety and
I've told the story but I think it's
worth telling again because you know
we're talking about yours and waking up
with anxiety though I have anxiety she
does so you get anxious oh no no I wake
up I have anxiety she was okay well um
what do you do about I go i light there
and what do you do I just lie there
until when does it there's a stop no
okay here's what I want you to do I want
you to get the [ __ ] up immediately
unless you're tired and you just woke up
for a second you're going back to sleep
go back to sleep but not get the [ __ ] up
and start your day and start doing
things go outside and you know it sounds
so stupid like how is that gonna work it
works just getting up taking a piss
taking a walk little things like that
but you don't take any pills right never
taking any medications never well I mean
no no nothing nothing prescribed for
anything to do with anxieties or
depressions or anything like that just
just run-of-the-mill if I have to take a
medicine I'm not an on medication person
but I fortunately have not had to take
anything for the anxiety and you sleep
well when you go to bed you are able to
fall asleep even if you're playing the
garden the next day you're doing
stand-up
you could still sleep knowing huh the
garden will be there when I wake up I've
always been okay with you know sleeping
especially knowing I've got big big shot
there's a weird comfort in knowing I've
got these ten theaters or arenas or or
shows any gigs lined up right now is
harder cuz I'm like I miss being on
stage tremendously
I miss the community I missed the
camaraderie even though we're all you
know comics you know texting each other
and all that I missed the visceral
reaction and it's been hard but I am I'm
grateful that I have the ability to
write write a book to the ability to get
on with a friend have some you know
laughs talk to you know scrap it a
little bit and talk about the good in
the bad hopefully somebody gets
something from this that's humorous and
heartfelt and then we go on our day and
know like we're just doing the best we
can with what we
have right here yeah and if I'm being
creative than I can at the end of it
it's funny when I started the book I was
talking to my I have a guy that like
I'll send once in a while be like okay
read this does this matter should be in
there am I gonna get sued for saying
this or that and this whole thing is I
kept saying like well this is my 30
years in stand-up I'm not really like
sure how it ends and he's like well at
least you have your ending now he's like
the pandemic is gonna be the final
chapter of this the first half of the
career hopefully longer you know I read
this that you know the whole Tonight
Show thing you were watching the tide
show with her mom and Carlin came out
with the the cutout of himself the
cardboard cutout right and then he it
was a car a cutout of himself and then
he just dropped it like that's the old
me this is me now [ __ ] off in a way I
mean how did that transom portent to you
right Barry talk to me about that very
important to me because although I came
up watching certain people in a in some
form of a character it always the thing
that impacted me in and at the same time
frightened to me was the idea of kind of
getting stuck in in a in a in a in a
character on stage you know I loved ice
and I'm friends with dice to this day
but me at that time was watching him
going oh what if he wants to do
something that's beyond the put on the
you know the pomp of this whole thing
and that used to make me very nervous
what's funny is I was already trying to
implement that into my stand-up you know
pretty early that carlin moment and now
I watch my early [ __ ] and I'm like I'm
like a black tank top and the gel in the
in the thing that I thought wasn't a
look is like oh my god that's like a
character now when I look at that so it
really is more than anything but for me
the karlon evolution when you watch you
know the 15 specials was him allowing
his behavior to grow and change the look
that he has will always be indicative of
the time but for me when you see my next
stand-up special it's my best stuff I
know it's my best stuff building on
everything else that I have
implemented and crafted to get to a
certain pedigree to be able to tell the
kind of stories and go even further in
word to be able to share that is is
because of Carlin because of the moment
of letting go of preconceived notions
well I think that's awesome that's also
really hard to do that's hard to do you
know and especially you know when you
look at yourself then you know even like
somebody was sending a picture of you
know I was such a dork in high school
and I was like aha they called me Spock
I had the Spock cut my senior year
whatever but I was lucky whatever
I just gotta look back on just different
things instead of just embracing them
this is who you were this is the kid you
were it's okay you don't be embarrassed
by this she'd do some kind of acting
role 10 years ago and gosh I wasn't that
good I thought that was good that was
but you're so quick to judge everything
we've done in the past we're here
because of the past
isn't it funny like you built you've
built an iconic character a lot of
people know you from an iconic character
you put your stamp on it you made it
original unique you made it textured
it's it's it's a character that is
exists existed for so many years in
different ways shapes and forms and yet
your you were remarkable in that role
why would we not want to go yeah I did
that that is me yeah today that that
piece of me with only those tools was
able to to carve out this moment of
performance that I'm very proud of isn't
it funny how we can look on those
moments now be like you know I wasn't
all there but you had what it took yeah
you know what and I that's funny said I
am good at now at like if I I don't like
I watch myself but sometimes I'll watch
things and I'll go [ __ ] yeah yeah did
you're in the moment you committed you
did it [ __ ] yeah do you yeah you know if
somebody says oh you know somebody and
I'm pretty freaking humble but if
somebody says hey you were the best Lex
Luthor planet in the mimbar but back in
my head I go yeah I hope I agree with
him I don't say that but I'm like I
think you know between happens why but
you know you have to take it sometimes
and go guess take that in take what
they're saying appreciate what they're
saying and believe it
believe it it's hard to believe that
sometimes and it's taking me a long time
to believe that I'm worthy to believe
and I think a lot of people go through
that you know I've had to learn this
through time and I think this goes for a
performance as well and having had the
opportunity to play roles that are
outside of comedy and roles that are
based in comedy the thing that I look at
is anything that people quote of mine to
this day now I'm going on stuff that's
quotable like [ __ ] 20 years later the
stuff that people quote regardless of
the jeans you're wearing or the hair or
the [ __ ] the the show is over now
there's a different version of the show
all that aside the stuff that remains is
when you put your real truth into any
performance it it stays it has staying
power it's timeless and I feel that of a
role that you played I can look at the
pieces of my comedy that I know our
commitment commitment the commitment but
if you create okay it's like pop music
if you put out a pop song 15 years ago
and it's just fluff but real good fluff
like [ __ ] sugary like dopamine its
fluff but it dissipates in three or four
summers later you're not still going to
be listening to that particular song but
the songs that now 20 years later you
you go hit play [ __ ] turn that [ __ ]
up is because I believe something real
that that artist put in that moment in
that studio is what you're really
connecting to more than the manufactured
stuff that also gets put out there yes
and stuff like I don't want to watch
that movie again you know it's
subliminal I think it is it is it's one
of those things were like people make
fun of me cuz I love the 70s 80s it
called 70 eighties cheese and I'm like
man you listen to Christopher Cross
assailing all caught up in the reverie
every word is a symphony and you too you
put that on and you are on the ocean you
were like you're looking up at the
canvas of your sail and you are I'm
telling you it's how we laugh but those
songs they still have this that they
resonate for me I'm like there's
something touching maybe it's something
uh that I connect to I'm very good at
like I'll remember a song and I know the
date of the song I know I know it's
probably came out either and I'm gonna
say 81 or 82 that's it I won't miss it
by that you're connecting with something
organic yes that person truly felt to
put into that performance and I'll even
go on the other side of it there's
certain painful moments of my life that
are so diabolically painful and yet I
find myself like bringing them up in
kind of weirdly celebrating where I'm at
now having gone through that pain but
the reason I'm remembering them is
because those painful moments that
somebody did something to you that was
so hurtful those are just like that
[ __ ] Christopher Cross song it's so
real that you can't help but weirdly
enjoying it because you got some truth
even in pain you went that was real that
was a real thing that that person did to
me or said to me or put on me it's all
the same it's all entertainment
destruction if it comes from a real
place we still want to study it and talk
about it I I agree man I think it's uh
it's pretty cool you could do that could
you've had some [ __ ] up moments too
you've had like we talked about last
night you want to listen to the other
interview with Dane from a while back it
was uh it was amazing and I got a lot of
great feedback I mean it wasn't just I
remember you said immediately you loved
your podcast and then look that I was
they loved how open and vulnerable you
are and and people who had these sort of
ideas of like who Dane Cook was or like
even P appears or whatever and whoever
it was they were just like dude
I love Dane Cook it's just if you want
like we obviously didn't rehash a lot of
the stuff we talked about then but it
was it was moving it was amazing I and I
couldn't believe how open you were
because we didn't know each other that
well we kind of saw each other in
passing whatever but you are I think
that's why you're even happier than you
are I think that's why you're able to
you're able to embrace things good or
bad that happen and sort of say this is
what happened and yes you talk about it
because it probably makes you feel
better right yeah and it also informs
current creativity that's the best part
of anything that you look up on the
whiteboard that you've made it through
that you can kind of like what is that
that usual suspects where you're like
putting the threads in and seeing how
everything makes up the path of where
you've got good and bad the assailants
in the in the misdirection for me
everything goes into how does all that
stuff inform how I how I live and how I
create how I present to my fans because
that's all I'm good at I'm good at my
relationships I'm good at my performance
and there's a lot of things that
obviously I'm I would succeed terribly
in a lot of things I would fail horribly
in but I'm lucky that I have a lane
where I can use all that stuff and
express it in a way that hopefully was
always entertaining and moving yeah you
know name-dropper the late Carrie Fisher
told me once she has you know write what
you know and I remember I read postcards
from the edge and then I said Wow
cuz she wrote obviously postcards and
then I started writing I just started
writing these little vignettes of my
life this is the time when Todd Stevens
stood up for me and beat the hell out of
this kid who was picking on me and oh
this is a moment of this and these dark
moments that I wrote about I was like I
don't know but I was like you know
Carrie's pretty effed up she could
handle this and I gave her like 30 pages
of and I remember she looked at me and
she goes did this all happen I know yeah
she goes a lot of this is obviously
painful and I go yeah sure she is you
know how you get rid of that you just
you make money off it she in a way she
was like you know write about this it's
real and this is how you get rid of
this is you succeed from it her way it
wasn't saying but like if you have this
this moment and it's real sometimes
you're like I'm not gonna exploit that
but some moments are like they're
brilliant and instead of suffering going
on I kind of try to laugh about it and
try to write about it and maybe someone
will relate out there or somebody
somebody thinks that there's no way that
happened but that's funny like when I
[ __ ] my mom's for a coat I won't get
into that inside of you is brought to
you by fair harbor
I freaking am in love with these guys
this is a brother and sister business
Caroline and Jake and they used to surf
and they noticed a young age plastic and
crap coming up and they were both like
what do we do about this well they made
a bad I was gonna say ass bad ass
swimwear it's all about comfort for me
you know say goodbye to the old mesh
crap you get chafed you know we think
that the chafing and now it's replaced
fair harbor did it right they replaced
it with a comfortable supersoft
versatility liner like a boxer liner a
boxer brief liner it's softer than
anything you have ever felt before from
swimming exercising to lounging and even
sleeping fair harbor shorts are made
from recycled plastic bottles and to
date fair harbor has recycled over 2.5
million plastic bottles keeping plastic
out of waterways and off beaches these
guys are doing it right fair harbor is
now offering a kid's line so the younger
guys can say goodbye to mesh lining -
I'm telling you wait T up in fact the
next episode I'm gonna wear I'm gonna
wear a pair of these built in soft built
in boxer-brief liners and you're gonna
you're gonna see them because I'm gonna
stand up there Harbor makes products for
you to enjoy the places you love while
protecting those places at the same time
20% off everyone listening right now
head over to fair harbor clothing comm
use the code inside 24 20 percent off
that's inside 24 20 percent off and say
goodbye to mesh lining forever go visit
fair harbor clothing dot-com come on
alright listen this has been awesome by
the way the tour had to stop momentarily
right yeah I was filming my special in
July back in Boston see that step yeah
the next special but like anything you
know we're all on pause so you can't be
upset at it even though you are but
it'll pick up as soon as we're allowed
to so how many shows had had you done
before this can't he stopped in March
right I did all 19 in the second half of
18 was all like on the road stuff to
prepare for the special so fortunately I
got my couple of four years there to be
able to then take this time now to you
know read a book and and focus on I'm
shooting a series to a TV series that
I'm also writing and producing and of
starring so finish that out finish the
book and then as soon as they say I can
get back into Boston and film is special
then me and my crew are gonna be back
there are you ready to film it tomorrow
or would you need a week to kind of get
the juices going do a couple of clubs
appearances get it going and then go you
know it's like I watched your interview
with Swardson and it was like in that
interview I was recalling anyway I don't
wanna go down the rabbit hole there but
the whole the whole idea of stepping
away from the stage for even a short
amount of time when you're focused on
filming it every day that goes by feels
like a month that you've been away so a
month being off stage at this point
feels like I'm just starting over
I know it'll be alright once I you know
get into a groove but yeah I definitely
am gonna need a little bit of time to
reignite certain ideas and just get
passionate about certain pieces of
material again but if nothing else it's
like I just been working on
ACK Ovid chunk so I can at least talk
about how I've been feeling and what I'm
seeing during this time all right this
is a we're gonna wrap this up with some
questions this is shit-talking Rosenbaum
is some patrons of mine who are you know
supporting the podcast and these are
easy Nico P thick crust or thin
SiC
I'm a thin guy I like the pan kind of
crust but I'm not like a Chicago pizza
kind of guy I don't like it to be like a
[ __ ] lasagna you know what I mean
yeah I like extra sauce though I'll tell
you that much - yeah always have extra
tomato sauce
Bob Kay favorite decade and why gotta be
eighties so much great music what should
come on he didn't ask us but I wanna
know who is your go-to like two or three
bands I always bring up some Guns and
Roses will anything from Appetite for
Destruction let's see a lot of pop a lot
of eighties pop on it but like one-hit
wonder [ __ ] you're the man hey I just
died in your arms tonight that one's
good yeah of course we're like you know
you gotta go Toto I think we are you
know we talked about like Africa oh yeah
they don't have they won't one-hit
wonders their total had some good [ __ ] I
love Chicago so good little Duran Duran
anything anything eighties I listen to
80s on eight pretty much non-stop in my
house you know if I wasn't an actor or
whatever I could maybe I'm still do it
I'd love to be a DJ this is rose and
BOMs
80s on Sunday night 80s we got a request
from Dane Cook off the line this one's
from the Appetite for Destruction album
it's uh you know I'd love to do that
here's a kajagoogoo two shy shy Jennifer
Ann what is your favorite holiday look
at that question
I've never acknowledged that I don't
like I don't like Easter I don't it's
okay yeah holidays Halloween
Thanksgiving dinner oh yeah like jillee
such a pioneer celebrities making good
use of social media to connect with fans
looking back are you glad you did and do
you think that you had a lasting impact
on using social media to build a fanbase
oh yeah definitely I did I felt like I
was there during the the initial
enthusiasm of what it was to
able to do this and have a direct
connection with with your fan base so
yeah nothing but pride in that whole era
that I put into connecting with people
virtually Emily asks which is easier for
you stand up for acting in a movie
easier I mean everything's like with
acting especially comedy it's such a
collaboration and if you're not
volleying it like this it's not funny it
doesn't matter how funny I am if you and
I are in it together it's gonna suck and
then if your editor also is a person who
doesn't really jive with comedy it
doesn't matter what you did on the set
like later you're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] did they do what is that new so you
have control when you're doing stand-up
is what you're saying you have control
if you stand up is like at least that
direct like I said vessel to you know
the initial idea getting the last so
stand-up is easier even though it's a
lot of work
Sean w-what was your experience like on
Hawaii five-o would you like to take on
a more serious type of role like that
one in Hawaii five-o I did it because
they initially offered me the role of
Danna and I said no I turned it down
because I did not want the island fever
of living in Hawaii so one of the few
things that I openly say I I got a
direct offer I said no and then they
called me and said well you know we're
fans will you do something I was like
yeah making it like kind of a maybe bad
guy I'll be an old brother so we did
that and receive scariest moment of any
stand-ups that you've ever done was
there a moment where you're like
something happened something's you're by
almost fainted on Letterman my second
appearance I had a hundred and two or
three degree temperature I was dealing
with like the worst flu
I went on TV that night I remember my
mom calling me later when I was like I
almost fainted and she's like oh I know
you're a gray
she's like you looked [ __ ] gray you
look like I was watching a Zenith
television you were so great and if you
look at the sentiments I come out and
the adrenaline went up as I was already
feeling terrible and you see me walk up
to the mic stand and just grab it and
then just [ __ ] like hold it because
the whole world starts closing it on ha
ha and then thankfully I took one breath
and I'm like all right I'm trying to
like be cool like too cool Hey hi guys
hello
hi and then that thing opened up and I
was I was okay do you think that's ever
happened even with big calm comedians or
any comedians where they go out and they
pass how they faint I mean I've heard of
a couple people like dying on stage even
over the years over stress musicians
dying and I've heard of a couple of
comedians that made somebody laugh so
hard that somebody died during the show
and they thought they were fooling
around but I can't think of a comedian
that's ever like yeah I can't think of
that at the top but I do know there's
been some weird [ __ ] that's happening
crowds during shows Sophie M what last
one what three words do you want as your
epitaph on your grave to remember you Oh
God
to remember me three words on my grave I
mean do any my words you want no first
of all I'm gonna get cremated so I don't
like this idea of a [ __ ] glory
alright how about on a whiteboard
somebody just writes some [ __ ] Dane Cook
lived was Tim Cook was his way Dane his
way of six-time Mike next time and I
hope there is a next time
I'd love to be on your show I did always
like I feel like if we can have a very
transparent moment I feel like we're
building a friendship through your
program okay so program will text a
little bit here and there but I truly
feel like this is a unique kind of bond
that we have growing through this format
yes 100% I'm telling you after that
first
meeting with you it doesn't happen often
but I'm like I'm gonna hang with that
guy I like him he's genuine only the
only that not in a uh what's the word
opportunistic way I say that word
because I think I would be better
because of you you know I feel like
you're a good person I feel like I've
learned from you I feel like we were I
think there's an honesty I think that's
where we're trying to be honest and in
real as much as we can I feel the same
about you and I say that not only
through these conversations but having
now become a fan of I'll watch your show
in this I hope you take this as a great
compliment i watch your show because
sometimes i trust in you that i might
like that other person that I'm not
really sure if I'm interested in their
journey so I find that like by hooking
up with your podcast I'm watching and
enjoying people that I probably like
myself in you mentioned with other
people I'm going oh wow I didn't i
didn't realize that about that person i
I like that so that's the goal I
appreciate that with your with your
program well did God that you mean you
said I mean look at--look doing a
podcast as hard there's everybody their
mother has a podcast and I just like you
know my hope people like I just want
them to learn something I want somebody
to open up I want if they if they want
to I'm open I'm dysfunctional I have all
these things so when you open up and
people that's that's what it's about and
hopefully that you know that's what I
say just because you know when we get a
hundred and some thousand people will
watch a certain interview because you
know they like that actor it doesn't
mean you know guys maybe stick around
because you might like or get something
from Dane that you don't really know
that well or somebody else or my dumb
ass might throw something witty at you
our rapport has grown yeah I'm seeing it
people are seeing it like here which is
kind of [ __ ] cool I mean I just say I
don't have a lunch with you and this is
all over and hang we should wait a year
and just do it through this just have
lunch through zoom just just we're can
where it's a unique thing you're seeing
a friendship building through this
medium as opposed to like us saying oh
we were hanging the other night and
something happened we wanted to talk
about it we're we're
really building up a report here which i
think is kinda think it's kind of
interesting there you know cuz I don't
know what you're gonna ask me you know
what I'm gonna come at you with we're
not that familiar overall and yet right
coming more and people are getting to
see it and chime in on it they should
that's cool I hope one day I'll be
sitting in that chair and I'll get a
picture of me sitting in your chair your
beloved chair of since 1997 it's a 23
year old chair that she bought for
fifteen hundred dollars from a man named
we don't know but dude I love this I
loved every bit of it I want to be
texting with you and talking to you and
thanks for allowing to be inside of you
once again my friend Dane Cook I hope
you guys enjoyed that one thank you so
much again just a reminder thank you for
supporting supporting me in the podcast
if you could do anything
write a review subscribe on YouTube and
and and on audio as well on Spotify or
Apple podcast or however you listen to
it and keep listening folks I really
appreciate it okay I just want to read a
quick letter fan letter this is from
Jacob Oh Jacob oh I think it's Chikako
just wanted to thank Michael and the
team for this incredible podcast
experience I'm stuck at home for the
Cova 19 quarantine situation in alia is
pretty crazy my eyes ache from staring
at a computer screen all the time I'm
offering my help as a psychologist and I
found some relief and peace of mind by
listening to inside of you so thanks and
keep up the wonderful work well wow
that's really sweet
thank you jack a PO chicapu you say Jack
a PO I said you know I'm talking about
it's always nice to hear back that the
show is affecting people in some way so
thank you very much all my patreon
patrons I would say that you notice that
I would say all my patreon my patrons
top tier patrons here we go Nancy D Mary
B Leah s Trisha F Sarah V Yukiko Jill E
Brian H inning
Thank You Lauren G Nico P berry
Angelina G Jerry W Kevin R Emily K Bobby
Robert B Jason W Kristen K Andrew see
Alison Elm
Jason Dheeraj Joshua D Emily ass see JP
rocks raccoon Samantha em I don't know
what I said it like that
Samantha M Hamza be Jennifer n Stacy
beth-el Carly T Vanessa in the sky ream
Little Dream Jennifer s hi Janelle be I
actually every time I see a name I want
to say something but it'll add too much
time but I'm thinking of you all of you
Janelle be neil w tabitha 272 kimberly e
melissa see Mike a Jake em Catherine em
Jake Jack s Carly s Judith d R Amira
Chris F Sarah f JW Leanne P Darla W
Jackie P Rodrigo s Rachel see Travis be
Rea a Rea a meg indeed Mario M Tina J
and Jennifer C so thank you so much guys
it's just incredible credible support
system and it's nice to see your
messages and I and I try to write back
as much as I can but I feel like it's a
little family there on the inside of you
patreon oh so just a reminder to
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
that really helps if you're enjoying
this one you know it's just it's an
awesome move on your behalf you just
press subscribe on YouTube you could
watch them but you could listen to them
on Spotify Apple podcasts or wherever
you can listen to podcast and really
appreciate your support follow us on the
at inside a podcast on Instagram and at
inside a pod on Twitter and if we really
appreciate all your help
it really does help you might think and
what is mine gonna it does your little
subscription
[Music]